how's it going bros my name is pierre
bad welcome to the haunted Hell to reach
its a recently released game as a mod I
guess it's not really mod but it's made
by an engine that I don't remember the
name of our Dino and we're gonna become
horrible
I really don't know anything about this
game I turn I know I got a playoff Jacob
cuz not why did I pick Jacob
okay by that I don't think this is I'm
over Bible proof kill the minions to
banish evil encounter one Norma alright
let's do this
you did yeah hahaha lift one comes my he
garbage show the hammock good how about
dad how'd you like that you like that
when I should younger like that hmm
oh you drop the ammo all account oh come
on give me a break put up a cute little
Elin
that was cute that's beauty all right
knee can I kick them hmm come on that's
how I roll how that's not how I roll all
right you're not dead yet thank you
what's going on with that guy's face the
super yep
yeah dressed know what the heck is going
on this game is awesome
oh wow take ship it rock
chill freakin pal ye-yes what I'm
talking about get me their king never
been okay last one outer oh wow
it's a nice Club but no no no up okay
view the phobia be fun right there
that's what I'm talking that's not what
I'm talking about they're not free
oh man all right what Tuggle my dad Matt
are you talking about Willie
ah what is he look at me
Oh excellent excellent sharpshooting
they're pretty Hannah pink a compound -
oh [ __ ] they're out of knowing Oh what
the heck
yes
whereas I hate that even come from super
weird oh ah I need that oh never be too
careful
Wow this game is really cool
okay I go here now no bad I then why did
I jump down here oh yes / nur I being
naked
Wow okay well that's pretty cool I guess
yes no oh this is like an online game
for sure this is an online game for sure
let's try another map because why not
why don't hang out I don't even know I
am curious to see what this game is
about the Crusader is here i relly oh
yeah that's me and I have a shotgun
actually I don't
I am not ringing ringing bring it god no
moose but uh mr. n no way it can't
things I have this if I should
mess around
so any misreads man Oh beautiful haha
untouchable that's what I'm talking
about
[ __ ] take your top huh
you think your top huh come at me bro
come out - bro Nick Amaro
Nick Nick yes yes all right I got this
that's not problem McEnroe's how did you
just fly back oh [ __ ]
all right
alrights my assembly I want my freaking
Angie this is y'all ooh
yeah ah bad for my annoying okay let's
see if we can beat oh crap I'm running
out of ammo I want to beat my last high
score
I got to do I got to do something I mean
someone's got to be possible can't be
impossible
- how are there really many enough
all right soon out of my mom whatever Oh
pork okay I have my Cintiq let's go huh
all right
aDNA problem okay problem it's a problem
it's definitely a problem ah problems
everywhere problem I see problems and I
see problems it's okay
I like Rollins I mean sometimes there's
a problem
good okay mister I need a good freakin
mr. Fang that was not a really good one
come on fire whatever let's get I'm
sorry but I'm so screwed I can't do this
well you ain't if I need a cake oh crap
I'm just running away from them ah okay
I come on this ridiculous how many give
me wait miss Wren right oh okay right by
me no problem come on get out wow I have
a shotgun
really why does he never quit Jesus
right gave me brain that's what you get
you break again oh man I love killing
mother
ah man I hate this ain't never nice
Montmarte one mark Dumars well it may
work Jim I don't have a memo what the
heck just happened I don't even know I'm
dying I'm dying I'm dying I'm laying in
a cake then a kick comes back yes
that's beautiful right there
I am the grown-up black they go up here
okay Wow okay who's king speaking
goriias help mitigate then Oh Malcolm
yes yes I think I got something on me
huh
I got Dana kicks all over this might
destroy the house smell to restore lilo
let's go for that
finger tapa oh crap I really need to I
don't even know how I climb things okay
there we go
where is it
we're not I got it oh man
it's not good for my image I mean I
don't even have one with whatever all
right he's going I need this is
something I don't even know I'm dying
here I'm dying here okay what is this
what is a dish I want it that's for sure
Sam for the price one uh-huh don't what
do you want huh not sure
whatever whenever they never stop do
they okay
have an SNA is fine
all right let's go know from watch show
freaking hammer good I don't understand
where he's probably like do a German
priest black German priests or something
super weird oh come on I need it down
stopping him oh that does summer again
haha no problem
huh
I feel you're telling I'm gonna die whoa
- again I'm dead end this again I want
that Oh thankfully okay okay just come
at me bro whoa whoa whoa
she'll tell bro not even pick up stop ah
puker
wow really bye ha ha
[Music]
it's not good there's my girl candy that
one mo thank you
all right there we go I got shotgun this
game is really a really fun I'm not
joking okay I'm joking it's not fun ah
come on this whole thing I'm stuck
No ah that was pretty good I was pretty
good around I think I landed here and
Founder thirty thousand kills if you
have this game why not do a video
response see if you can beat my high
score
there was a second time though but
anyway ah that's pretty much it ah
[Music]
[ __ ] is that
my bed my boys